okay good evening everybody
I should start by reading the emergency
recreation announcing it should we be
required to evacuate the village need
you please link building or either
nearest available exit there is one in
piracy in this room you can need to
evacuate the room do so it's going to be
external wireless main staircase please
hold handrails in closest days of wet or
slippery if anyone is unable to use the
stairs but they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the
fluoroscope door where they can be given
assistance our assembly point you'd be
in the public car park at the side of
the sitting swiftly please do not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building and give them permission to do
so by council staff please also note
that this meeting will be recorded and
[ __ ] remind you to switch off your
mobile phones or turn them to the side
okay item number one on the agenda
apologies for absence and you have
received a quality strong council
kidding cancel the meal and counsel
substitute members we have a councillor
Marik substitute for council good
counselor mrs. Leung me substitute for
council a meal and those steps of truth
including any emergency planning Thank
You members and happy new year just by
way of introduction and forum for Jeff
station my colleague just so you all
aware Jeff background is role in the
across the performs of the council Jeff
Zacks you were this back in the early
nineteen ice Ridge '''l II and his role
then was the Essex County Council
emergency planning officer he then moved
into a more senior position there as the
County Emergency Planning Officers leant
back back to RDC
council in the nineties also supported
etheric and other district councils in
their mercy planning he also held other
roles across Suffolk and merging
planning go east and the Portland's and
authority as well so we're quite
fortunate to have Jeff with us in his
experience the report across the team a
real mixture of first national regional
and district expertise which mean so
helpful when moving the service for the
last couple of years just by way of
introduction of the report which have a
chance to enter review follow the
similar format that we have presented
the reports in previous previous
committees so just to sort of
highlighted a couple of points in there
that might be as I said so we employ the
council boys emergency planning and
business continuity officer which is
Jeff Stacey that made was us as a
council to meet our legislative
requirements under the civil
contingencies act 2004 that's an effect
legislation sets out how we have to plan
for and deal with civil contingencies so
that also sets out how we coordinate and
cooperate with other responding agencies
and planning for emergencies
we're sure that we can maintain the
services throughout any instance in the
form of business continuity planning as
well the report sets out that emergency
planning is is risk based so in general
terms the green to the risk would
receive the largest share of available
resources
this is allocated for planning and
preparation thirdly reports and this
report alludes to how we set out our
approach to emergency planning through a
recognition of national risk registers
County community risk registers and how
that affect us at a local level
so in particular response to widespread
emergencies the council we've more
interested with dealing with such as
risk to the to the airport flooding the
mo d activities on fowl mess and other
local coastal pollution issues for
example
closely linked with emergency planning
of course it's business continuity -
this would concern accountability to
maintain its services in the
major disruption or incidents for
example loss of access to the officers
due to a fire or other less severe
incidences and that response is based on
reprioritizing our resources to meet the
needs of the incident so you'll be aware
that this would have an effect on almost
service delivery that's about how we
plan to maintain their services through
such incident we do work with other
agencies to support those affected in
recovery we initially do this through a
meeting of the council leadership team
where we look to reprioritize resources
to meet needs of our residents while
still maintaining our critical services
across the council we have a number of
generic plans we've previously presented
to this committee that sets out in very
simple terms as a council how the Legion
team we set out to guide our colleagues
through such instances they're all
available on our website should you wish
to look at them three simple plans in
terms of our response to an emergency
our merge the Information Center and
also communication three simple plans
but crucial for us should a large
incident occur how we are how we go
about setting out our our response in
terms of report itself it details
various areas some key areas in there we
refer to such as emergency volunteers on
rest centers are out of hours response
and traveler encampments to name a
couple of sections in there hopefully
reports self-explanatory to say Jeff
joins us light and my self will just be
happy to take any questions from my help
thank you very much it's a random point
five and the emergency volunteers and
just one question under five point three
I'll be talking about three thousand
event a city that that paragraphs a
little bit confusing since the
councillors are in reasonable number as
emergency bonds
in relationship its overall staffing
level but the intent is to recruit more
with the help of an attractive training
program countless people in tears
because if you are looking to train more
volunteers because I don't think I've
ever been invited to inventing so I just
love to do that so we could be part of
yeah yes the volunteers that we've got a
members of staff so yeah we do through a
specific training program with them to
take undertake some particular roles
such as a rest center such as operation
of the emergency information center and
with them being members of staff
obviously we certainly doing the the day
to take those on as part of their other
duties the difference with the
volunteers is they've also volunteered
to help us out at ours as well so we can
we can call upon them in that way in
terms of volunteering generally it is
something that nationally has been
subject to to a lot of debate certainly
we would welcome any elected members to
volunteer and come in to assist on the
on the day a in terms of the wider
volunteers as I said that's something
that we're looking at nationally I've
recently attended
as a sort of pioneering course that
they're looking to deliver on how this
will happen so I think I now have a sort
of clear idea of how we can achieve that
within a sort of a district and that's
been something we've been running out
during 2020 we have offered in the past
if you would like to do some specific
training for example on how a rest
center runs or something like that
yes I'm more than happy to sort of look
at fitting that into the into the member
training I think the Pearson's to
officers about members involvement and
in fact I think we have made it a
recommendation before as a committee
that members shall be more involved
we've identified as that committee that
if there was ever an emergency residents
are probably more likely to contact us
out of hours and as cancer Macpherson's
alluded to I don't believe any of us
have ever been contacted or approached
with a view to understanding the
procedure that we would need to learn to
take it and as I said this is the third
time we've had the same conversation and
it's not really mentioned in this report
I think it's gonna be something that a
lot of members are in agreement of that
really does now need to be implemented
and as a chairman just coming back on
that some of us do have the training
already in place and do support the
emergency services and some of their
activities Matt will know
the Olympics you know local trained
quite a few of us so we've got skills
there and we are the link as well with
some of the parishes as well as the
militants as we know our world better
than most nothing good like I say in the
event of emergency even not in the event
of obviously we are contacted by
residents out of hours anyway I think
it's a real missed opportunity at the
current time that you're not involving
members more and cancel mrs. Mason
you've indicated that that was on the
same thank you I've no need also Council
Berta says no I can recall mean it must
be a year or so ago a very similar
conversation when members felt they were
being excluded from operating this now
for example my ward there have been two
emergencies
one was a flooding and one was that the
cilia ghastly with evacuations on both
of those occasions I was notified by
residents the council never contacted me
which is not good because there's two
issues there one is I had to find out
they're going investigate and ascertain
what the problem was and try and deal
with it and secondly I could not really
sure or inform the Reston so I do think
that there's a communication problem as
well so you've got the problem with
members saying that they want to be
volunteered but when it's in their world
or in their vicinity they should also be
informed so there's at there's two
issues there that I think need
addressing and looking at further so
that's certainly with the volunteers did
you actually say that part of the
project was the production of a joint
training package used in late 18 and
early nineteen is that all going because
it's a year after date they're already
has it changed you know
but yes we can speak and still use them
so that's it that is still an old method
ongoing process because training
normally needs to be reinforced and I'm
concerned if it's emergency training
that happens so rarely that the training
needs to be perhaps more vigorous than
it would be for a routine practice yes
certainly customer tonight I think
that's us okay Thank You Jeremy yeah
just to pick up on on the training so I
mean but that certainly is an ongoing
piece of work I mean it's it's rigorous
training it's ongoing and it's as Jeff
said this was the first time all
districts and very springball together
in one form or single process so it was
you know an innovative training to make
your a straightforward
it helped us with our own cross-border
work use well in terms of you had some
of the processes certain the first time
that's been done but yeah it's ongoing
training these becomes attribute so
we'll certainly yeah that happens to
matter of course if I could just come
back in on the on the communication of a
kid I'm sorry cess of mine from the
previous meetings and that both means we
had I've already checked the mate and
our own notes and what's produce but we
did produce a communications protocol
which was was spreads about to work
through the team about how working with
members be also did some member training
with members about dealing with comms in
an emergency so this was around should
be happy to should have member to be in
front of the media for example how to do
that situation I believe it was the lead
and the deputy leader I think we did
yeah that's something
thank you yes so that was about how to
in a in a larger incident and should
they need to be speak to the press about
how to deal that that's arranged for
training sort of running some sort of
some scenarios and they're having some
questions find out you Lygia team had
did that as well very useful piece of
work we crawled an out further but there
was some further work traffic and
remember on where we looked at in terms
of the communication cooled down so
cooling down through lead or detective
leader should have Largent occur how we
then fed through
first portfolio holders and you know
made those those commissions so we can
pick it up again it was looked at that's
in place we have that ability to do that
we can look at that further should we
need to just picking up on
communications in terms of how that's
done as a from an officer perspective
through our out of our service as
mentioned in the report to tender and
care line do that currently so it should
be aware so any that they can be
contacted 24/7 they'll take the initial
action so in most of time I can deal
with that and either through at a time
or if it's not a foreign emergency they
can pass on turn off the next working
day they have bright detailed list of
instructions but various instances and
that may occur anything from poultry
anything I was already back to would
deal with through to the more serious
emergencies if they can't deal with at
the time they then call one of the
Encore with emergency officers are
available and turns my face a year I'm
out of a lot of [ __ ] on me yes ten drink
airline called he was cool he met
officer he would call that office
anybody member the public any beer -
where would they find the information
it's on our website because I it is on
the website it's really not easy to find
okay and compared to other websites on
they on the front homepage they often
have either red box or some way that
directs the person in an emergency and
you can click on that and it's very very
clear there are very clear instruction
of what to do not can't find on our
website at all okay we could look at
that there is yeah I think it's just
with all the contact numbers if there is
an emergency
people don't you scrolling through a
website and looking for
you do it's depending on the nature of
the emergency I think it's an emergency
emergency the neighboring 999 if they
need that sort of response that they
don't bring emergency service it's not
the council I mean this there's no
virgin out of hours things that we would
respond to in the same sort of way if
it's something that needs urgent
response that's the emergency services
that's what they are there for if there
is a need for company to be dealing with
our emergency calls out of hours then
there should be clear instructions on
how to contact them we think that the
point may configure mine external
website that's of simplex if that's not
as clear as it could be we can get that
and improve so I just need to come talk
about the Chairman's points I don't
think he's been on say the only time
I've ever been contacted was by Mr Dave
during some flooding issues sameiras go
the flooding did not happen but he
actually kept me up to date that's the
only time ever that anybody from the
council's fo phoned me and kept me in in
the move that was happening in my board
about problems not a there was a someone
died there once and those also kept in
look about that but that beyond that
nothing else happens and the Chairman is
right it's at least three times that
we've asked for this that we are I was
kept in the loop if they're easily
emergency in my homes do you think I'm
going to be asleep in bed with waiting
everyone else a bit of people probably
be at the center do staff know how to
deal with me if I'm not being trained
for it they've got to be aware that I'm
not trained if I'm trained they might
then I have some use for me and that
goes for most of us if not all of us I
would say so and there's no flavor from
this report what happened you have to
expect that we will be there you might
be cutting us out in here but in reality
we will be there and we will be involved
because that's the night room that's
probably why we have counselors for a
start because we like to be involved
we'd like to help so you've got a
recognized fact that we will be there
and do wander stay untrained or June as
they're trained or would think the
lighter the letter
sorry chairman quiet I think about it
with regard to the out-of-hours can I
just go on to that because that was the
other probability right yeah I've had
problems with it in the past this report
says nothing different to any other
report I've read about out of hours how
often do you test the outer veils yeah I
mean the what what happens is the I mean
basically the it's a review more less
every time they get a call in terms
that's dealt with so can I just say how
do you know if the call is answered I've
rung that line and not being answered
yep so you need this needs to be text
I'm sorry chairman I think I'm quite I
think you're fine about this for me
because it does not work and I've used
it and 100 City I'll do get through
sometimes I've never managed to get
through and something has been dealt
with at that point I've have people
without a home or anywhere to sleep and
I cannot get through I understand I know
how I eat these numbers so stuff now
have a mobile phone assistant director
and I probably found that but that's me
members of the public if they're out
without constant contact of accounts
then what do they do they're not gonna
find a 9 9 9 for a bed for the night
are they if they've been evicted on a
Friday evening at Paintsville 8 p.m.
this is the issue I've also had issues
of laundry line being blocked by
fly-tipping which maybe it's his County
Council but it's across over and it was
definitely a ruptured council issue
which was then passed on to somebody
else the police weren't interested and
that got lost as well and there's other
occasions when I've found up and there's
been no answer so angry about that but I
think I think it needs to be rigorously
tested and perhaps
the information could be provided how
many calls we've probably made to that
these are my dear members no I mean
certainly with me too we detect it away
we can look at some do some masses on
now we humbly made aware of any calls
that have being dropped out on Miss
Bertha control here in the mouth so we
can take it away like just sorry it's
pretty go back on the comms point if I
may it's worth touching on and because
we mentioned assistant directors there's
also a duty ad system as well so there's
them as the Henry Caroline number who
will contact the on-call officer the on
Kloster will then contact the duty
assistant director part of the
communication protocol that was
developed after the last two meetings
set up a process so for the larger more
serious emergencies that ujd would be
forwarding the leader the deputy there
and also group leaders to them just
immense information through that will
plan out there is a system in place and
that's what the duty will be there to be
responsible for doing we can do some
more further work with the GGA with the
v-chip team to reinforce that message if
that's not getting through but that
certainly was the protocol was great in
place and I am certainly if if you can't
need to trouble with calls you may take
care and I do please let me know and
I'll follow up with them fine why they
do record all the calls and things so go
back through and find out exactly what
happened and and so if you didn't get
through then no I can take that I can
take that with okay
so please please sure I'd like to come
back in the first place and I'm still
not being allowed to come back okay
yeah because I think these are the two
issues were the two that I was going to
race the first one is the month
emergency volunteers which I think I
think we've all agreed we won that big
call back here he says plenty ham
members are going to be involved because
three years is unacceptable I thought we
do but the contact the out of ass
contact is ineffective so you need to
put another means of communication in
with
and I'll tell you what we've had various
issues in our world where I've had to
contact them in some cases I've managed
to get through and then I get an officer
about half now an hour later and
eventually that situation with but if
it's an emergency
the term emergency in the prompter is
months and in no case even when we've
had traveling cashiers hasn't been a
prompt response at that time is a
bastion number wasn't engineering so I
don't know if it's incredible the other
issues were when we had flooding so when
the emergency is of a greater nature
than perhaps at one of incidents and
obviously plugin tends to affect more
than one area thing that service fails
so we need a communications with members
and with ward members and I think we
have asked that before and I would like
to see that reported back to this
committee that chair also great
[Applause]
german-soviet you'll talk about the
communication protocol with members is
about line in terms of the gjd system
well I think that's in place that
currently we can we can set out further
that's helpful for members we can
certainly put any report but that what
we can because members are still not
procedures fine okay thank you I know
that's helpful so I think so and we can
bring back and we we can look further at
some further training but that in a
report and in terms of the
communications protocol which which is
out there already but we can look to and
resurface out put that in front of the
leadership team again and I think that's
one element
is the involvement of members in
emergencies Jemma green I think that's
what it's the train will pick up and how
we can do that again we've looked at
that previously but we can we can do
that again to do that are concerning
comment now on some of the issues that
you've sort of raised there and I mean
certainly in terms of the training no
problem I have offered to do that but
the member training list is quite formal
so it's quite quite difficult to do to
get that on but if that is a priority
the what we've done in the past is we've
done general training on some
emergencies and the response to
emergencies so I can do that again and
if you particularly want to do some more
training on the communication side we
can do we can do that again as well so
so we can do both of those that's that's
not a problem just a question I think
I'm sorry I'm going to disagree with you
quite strongly because I was chairing
the subcommittee for training we went
out over a year ago and again this year
and we asked officers and members for
what they wanted to spend training what
to consider that no time
remember training for emergencies cannot
that hasn't been put forward
it hasn't been put forward at all so
move the office well it hasn't been
communicated that's all I can say
chairman we can certainly bring that
back yeah additional question which is
used yes sir well the time back was
released report I said on the first one
into the minutes on the reveal the 12th
of June 18 and it says the a similar
session covering various aspects of
emergency planning could be offered
against all members okay what I want Mel
type every meeting we have in every
training we have in my books and you've
never been offered that back
2019 so we as mrs. Mason say it hasn't
been offered to us and raining I think
this is for missile I suppose as you say
we we are the first port of call with
residents in we've got a problem they
come to us and we have to go and talk to
the guys you know on the thing so we
need to have proper training and you
obviously need training three point one
since the leadership team continued
continue with exercises to reinforce the
way in which they respond to emergencies
the most recent was in October 19 which
was the leadership team to set a
strategy to deal with a pollution
incident in the river crap that's
perfectly acceptable
what would ask is who chooses for the
exercises that you undertaking and how
do you measure those the success of
those particular sizes statistics or
procedures tick box exercise it varies
depending on the exercise some it's
purely I mean like the the one we
mentioned the river crouch
it's basically yeah I do an assessment
and feedback on the response by the
leadership team into requirement some we
will do a formal sort debrief we're so
we get people together and we run
through what happened and what response
was how we do it better next time
you know requires us to change our plans
or anything like that some of the larger
exercises that we get involved in with
partners so we do the same sort of
debrief but it's then a multi-agency
debrief so that we've we've got a
peoples coming in from other
organizations and other agencies so
you're getting that that sort of level
of independent assessment as to how
we're done so it depends very much on me
I mean clearly do any time do you think
that perhaps our responses or how we
respond to them or how you love them
should be independently looked at to
make sure that we do we do get an
independent view on our response with
some of the bigger exercises that we do
because we've when we do the debrief
where we're getting a partner view on
our response and how we've responded to
it so say yes we do we do get that
independent view officers looking
closely at cyber threats does the
council have cyber insurance
I wouldn't know and my side of things is
the consequence management so so if it
fails what do we do in terms of
responding as much for District Council
to not having any MIT that question is
had to direct to another officer
we could break one our chairman in terms
of emergencies not just the system going
down but systems being hacked I mean
obviously our computer system model
store hijacking an insurance policy
would assist because the insurance
companies that provide those are trying
to do I will ask a question of this is
threat to customer and nothing like
thank you scheme to recover costs just
out of interest there's no hard and fast
rules for it it's it's basic the scheme
by which we can apply to government for
financial assistance and they they have
many years ago trying to sort of set
exactly what it meant it just got too
difficult so so it's basically a fairly
open-ended scheme if we can make a good
enough case for financial assistance
following an emergency just going back
about volunteers that don't have fun too
much because we haven't good or we're
all working through so we have agreed
that that's gonna be included as
training for volunteers but my original
question is well included up I as a
counselor would like to undergo this
training right that helps you to be able
to run in emergency and information
center open Iraq red centre actually the
hands-on training that you give to the
staff I think that we should be open
members thanks
yeah it's interesting because if
something happened won't you leave you
know flooded with something where would
be 40 and I'm literally just gonna whip
something w yes I've got your militancy
to come on other than water district has
two contacts he's come out out of errors
it looks to me like a better than number
yes yeah we kept the number the same
tendering is we'd you see the number we
use before to keep consistent it has
been a number first on me chairman just
off away then he will that you should a
theme not people have restored that
number it's gonna stay the same indeed
so I do understand some are signs on our
open spaces and okay but I know as well
when I was leader at the council I used
to get regular reports of people who had
called the emergency number and what
they called about I understand it goes
all of them go straight to the head of
service as well
anytime is that correct is that still
the case they we do with think are is in
a number of ways if we talk about
dealing with that I'm saying the report
yeah it's actually money these actually
comes up to the head of service at that
time yeah you go real time and it goes
to customer services and then customer
services depending on you know how it
needs no no we are becomes right from
the used to come straight from the
emergency wherever it was and does a
little tender II used to be to be
president at the time I didn't used to
go straight to the end of service no
it's no longer the case
I think you should because if there's an
emergency the head of service should
know about it and oh well if you as a
phone call this yeah I would just finish
what I'm saying
hmm there's a phone call to the head of
service that he's asking for a paper or
any one of the emergency services asking
about something that they should be
fully informed yes the and say we have
these different sort of categories of
calls that they take out of ours if
we're looking at emergency call then
that goes through the on-call officer
they would talk first of all to whoever
is the duty assistant director but if it
relates to specific areas that they
would talk to the assistant director for
that area I think you're confirming
while saying it doesn't go into the air
service let me turn them to to do it
properly
yeah Jeffrey plants out of hours
emergency in that kills officer it would
be it'll be a fun cool straightaway of
your phone call from care line to the
on-call officer to do JD do shady to the
MD or cheat erector and then from there
absurd leader one deputy and crib
leaders okay just one last point German
it was quite giving my mind that number
as you did finding Indians would make
two or three goes so we do that a
national way we can get that raised
arrest part
any other job was not stree clarifier
useful from my notes members of our
formation on so trained members specific
around rest centers and our response to
an emergency is what I'm hearing also
information around our communications
protocol which was set up so to have
relaunched out in the report filter to
reservation with yes protocol with no
more specifically yes yeah change now no
training good now general you me I think
yeah training training we can actually
be part of volunteered training I think
we're talking about yes correct
as opposed to sort of same training in
the training sessions which we can look
at separately volunteers
and perhaps also if you could also
include in that report with regards to
I'm assuming you will go back and under
undertaking review of where the
emergency number may appear on the
website whether or not you it you feel
that that could be move to more
prominent position if not the reason why
it shouldn't be I'm sure I can be
rectified it's not you know that need to
be continued because the boy also cooked
up a question of testing a emergency
number when we tests fire alarms or
smoke alarms and I do think that there
should be a testing regime put in and
I'd like to see that in capitalist in
the update I'm not not saying that it
should be done every day or every week
but they should be random testing done
so that you're happy that that system
that you put in place works
I would reinforce if you do have problem
contacting Jeff you just said that if we
you know this is just made a mockery of
it really if we have go to the emergency
line and it doesn't work who then do we
contact I can't bring music if we've got
emergency on the Saturday I can't spring
you on the up in the office on Monday so
- I do work we've got emergency so who
do we actually contact if that lines not
working please continue to ring it
because they and I say I'm not aware of
there ever being any problems with the
line I mean they have some about 50
operators on various ships and things
like that are plenty of operators there
are plenty of lines so I mean that was
one of the things that we looked at
you know in terms of how they answer the
calls and the staff they have available
a number of lines that could make
available that sort of thing which is
why I'd be very surprised if people
haven't got replies and why I'd like to
know that
well things that I always actually look
at that but it is a significant
organization that deals with that and
it's not temporary provide that service
not just for us for others as well so we
can take away and look about it that
concerns were here I think I am
concerned about that ended up we
couldn't get through my husband at the
times on the council we couldn't get
through we couldn't even get through to
the police initially though we did
eventually and we ended up we now
wearing some bows wading through
floodwater stopping traffic because it
was aggravating the situation with the
proper authority but at no time we
managed to get in touch with the council
what did the council communicate with us
now that was I would called the series
properties were flooded it was a serious
situation and it was one that was
deteriorating so I think else the shots
got very good point I think there may be
a number that we're going to flash up
and but in prominence on the website
which they should be for residents but
they should be the secondary emergency
number for members in case of need
because I'm certainly not my confidence
in the emergency number is rather
lacking which is why I think that the
point of testing might very sure us and
it may have improved since that time and
I'm hoping it has but we're expressing
concern and perhaps one way of
alleviating that concern perhaps you
could come back in April as well and
with practice if the testing and
episodes unreasonable that's fine but we
need needs to be no time cheffy just say
well definite the way and we'll do some
we can do some testing I watch this
grasp as mrs. BAE I went into the water
we tachi check that
it's different company entirely of
course in bacteria operators 250s
in Japanese importance to make that
point that things have moved on since
then in terms of the system are now
working with now there's a different
provider we're saying to do some checks
on it but assisant how certain moved on
from then and improved but we're second
edition checks on missus yeah
have you ever found that line say nine
o'clock at night to test it or I'm not
saying on Sunday afternoon to see how do
you know Table four back to my regular
basis but you don't still know Jeff in
the rabbit don't call officers through
an instant you do so i personal call to
myself bill officers would have to deal
with them that back-and-forth
conversation that's one what s is real
life yeah because a number the own good
officer with blowing that number to
doubt that one-to-one yeah ran into them
so first I myself always have done it
but we completely here manage concerns
what is interesting
thank you for attending okay members
item number seven reporting process from
review committee to Council there isn't
a report this item has been added a
crystal counselor mrs. Mason and I think
we're looking to seek clarification on
the teaching process review offices to
counsel yes it's a small point and it's
not really a big issue but what I'm
hoping to do is to get some clarity
before it becomes more of an issue at
the previous meeting in December we
asked for members to be made to the
midterm Treasury review and that was a
great I mean we've just agreed two
minutes it was a credit for that report
would be presented to council with
amendments what normally has happened in
the past the best of my knowledge is the
women report is amended it's so good if
anyone's got in common with me they
comment back east we probably it's
circulated among many people we
circulated to member something we see
has happened in the past but this time
it didn't happen so I wonder if the
obviously can explain why the report was
not amended but he said it was
supplemented by an additional report
which is basically from what I can say a
rehash of the minutes which were at that
point
proved with the maintenance on it so
instead of having an amended report
there was a report that said this report
it's a report of the review committee
that the review committee had not seen
until came out with they thought Council
Mini's yeah okay so we saw it at that
point but it happened to be from the
review committee but we haven't seen it
clarifying the original report that we
are amendments to was presented to for
Council then as an appendix yes and in
addition to the appendix were the
additional information or was the
additional information that we had asked
the in addition to leave it in addition
to the original report there was a whole
lot of stuff that we hadn't asked to be
presented to Council which affects
please the minute but how it half of it
is identical to a minute which we hadn't
asked and then at the bottom was the
information we had asked for so it was
confusing to say the least
I'm not that one's really rehash that
but what I'm saying if a report comes
from this committee to--for Council this
committee should say it first that's all
I'm saying and in this case we didn't
okay I think they just did it yesterday
just to recap on what was presented at
full council having spoken sexual Bob
Walker so that was she was advised two
percent was in in
when I've circulated the quarks in the
past for approval it's usually one of
the working groups and that's why I live
circulate it like that when we've always
done the treasury management reports in
the past we always put them as an
appendix and as you probably noticed
wake up enticed some minutes for that
that item to make sure that everything's
covered and put it on the cover in
report okay in this case we had a table
there was additions to that table which
was put into the covering report wasn't
putting into the appendix so it didn't
misrepresent what was originally
presented to the review committee but
that's what we had asked for yeah you
know okay in hindsight perhaps we should
have said in that table to members so
they could have seen it beforehand know
what was coming and okay I'll hold my
hands up yes we didn't do it I haven't
got a great issue about the fact that it
wasn't done without did cause some
hiccups but there the issue is that
perhaps going forward we could make sure
that even report says it is from the
review committee that is from the review
committee it's as simple as that really
I don't know how other members feel but
I just feel that if it says this is a
report that the review committee that we
should have seen before it's circulating
you to outside the committee the only
issue I would have
is quite often we're up against the
deadline I think in this case we have a
meetin on the Tuesday be able to get the
report out on Friday I actually wasn't
in the tall after the committee meeting
and the minutes were done by about
Thursday evening and so I hear what
you're saying and if we can do it the
next full council maiden would have been
feathering in which case this treasury
management strategy report would end up
as well yeah this is a common yes it
would be lovely if we had a little bit
more time and perhaps in hindsight the
treasury management reports should go in
the November but I'm not sure Naomi's
gonna be very tough with me for
suggesting that hmm that's up to this
yeah this or in future and that's
something that we should consider but
yeah I'm just saying going forward time
if time permits he has no reason why
amended report shouldn't be circulated
to the review committee first
yeah well even if not for common it's
long as it's so 91st then if anyone's
got any common they can make it rather
than at that time it's already
circulating to the howl of the council
we received it with the rest of the
council yeah that was the only Asian
cancer is the one no doubt I think it's
just good to retry the point though
members of we as members of the review
committee saw that that report at the
same times other members we could ask
questions only a meeting but that points
about in reality I suppose we could have
phoned up you and more the officer a bit
about him why is it in their format you
manage your meeting that's any of
opportunity we have to ask questions on
it or to query it because you sent
you've got a new report at the front
original report how do you try to find
the right words we are then asking
questions about a report that other
members think we've read in full and
have agreed already when reality we
haven't and that's one of the issues I
think that I have one that they haven't
often isn't the problem as cancer mrs.
Mason said often it's not really a
problem but there was quite significant
changes yet to that report one I think
it caused some problems I mean in future
I will try and get them out to you if
you can save them you might find it very
tight times you know I'm quite happy to
try and I think secondly I think the
members can understand perhaps why this
one didn't quite yeah so just that
Charlotte would have cut down the amount
of work that you had to take because
that's all we needed really but the all
we needed was the information that we'd
asked to be a man who didn't they the
rest of us sometimes it's it's easier to
give a flavor of what's been raised this
showed that the committee have actually
considered that report because if I only
just sent the title I'll put the title
there and then you could find other
members gun but it didn't ask many
questions but that's in the minutes yeah
yeah I think I could understand why it
happened but I think think your
suggestion and having the midterm
Treasury report in November is perhaps
something that we ought to consider for
next continue and
we did have a one-point a subcommittee
we would do and that made it a little
bit easier because we they were mating
midwife but there isn't enough of the
work program at the moment to make or
really warrant and the members have
decided to have a subcommittee but we
could do that next year
that's not then that's a consideration
really for 20 20 20 to 22 years later
perhaps you could make a note of it
inside so that is considered in the
money yeah it does actually come up on
the 4th of February yeah strategy but so
that be the next one and that's it I
have to point in that's even worse then
they include it in their in the budget
one thank you know so if it's a small
point okay because nothing's changed
other that's been added you stood on the
brownfield sites but then James be made
this month so it will clear it
next month we have the treasury
management strategy statement and a new
investment strategy and minimum revenue
provision for policy statements so it's
the gender e-learning planning we've
just added yeah it'll be an updated
emergency planning emergency plan in the
2nd of April who's the chair of the CHP
at the moment is it Rockford's turn at
the moment was it castle points will
they answer yet attendance or whatever
yeah well I represent if you don't it
may be as well I've actually gone
meeting with young Dean on variety and I
haven't mentioned to base before since I
come back Christmas sir
Abby no idea I would imagine they
I think it might be useful for someone
from this yes because I think we quite
often I we you can get to it I had like
a meeting the police sometimes and talk
about specific qualities about Putin
like better question that CSP
represented all terminally it's about
fun person any questions for there now
but I'd like to know how they've spent
her notes on your school budget they
have no spent the funding that they do
get I mean I think the questions in
advance are always welcome you know if I
maybe not this evening I think members
would have to if members want to email
me with any questions they've got are we
asked the questions are covered in the
report
I'm not sure they've got the information
if that's useful ask a question we've
had a peer review which was actually due
to be circulated to members on the 22
said but we haven't received it yet I
wasn't honest with us on that title is
it either something that would be pretty
look so because obviously it's a report
of the activities of the council and I
wanted if that's something that a time
of your sojourning that a committee
would look at I
don't worry when you get a peer-reviewed
a members not really get a clear review
out of that will come an action plan so
perhaps the action plan could be looked
at by the review committee that might be
a way for yeah I think the last time
correct me if I'm wrong I think it went
to council Oh remember this as a matter
of course yeah because there's none
reason why the review committee I look
at it works all members will get so mad
at the action plan and everything else
Germany if if we haven't seen the peer
review and we are answer questions on
the actual plane what it was meant to be
absent we haven't seen the peer review
and we talked about twenty thirty seven
thirty houses carefully I was like no
that's fine your time working yeah
that's probably with direct comments and
I was told the facts tricky I think the
way it works they send the first draft
lettering and officers get chance to
comment whether that's correct and pick
up any detail I think that's how it
works but the heels because you've got
an outside body looking at you sometimes
they don't all the effects correct and
so you do need a sort of so this is
weird it seems a correct any minute
well it's [ __ ] further for the IEDs
yes but once the action plan comes out
and I think that's that's the sort of
what you would criticize you know look
at this the right way forward
no you reduce or make mr. Munoz is kept
the council that reduced that from the
information but there is agreement with
those
the head of the peer review that you
know that it's all follows through with
a recommendation typically but they're
only recommendations I think if you come
into good suggestion nothing your
members in agreement
[Applause]